no introduction he was one of the
driving forces behind
fodzy although he claims no
responsibility for the name
mike's also one of the the leaders of
the research theme on economics and
learning and that's
what he's going to be telling us about
this morning
all right thanks peter and uh pleasure
to see all of you i wish we were in
person but
um that'll happen someday let me do a
little share screen here i'm getting
actually good at zoom
that's the one thing i've gotten out of
this whole period um i should not say
that it'll
jinx me however all right so
okay so let me just first of all say
that um
i'm no expert on microeconomics why am i
talking about it
um well because every 10 years i like to
work on complete something completely
different that i never worked on before
and so in this case it's it's going to
be blends of
microeconomics with machine learning um
so i'm really excited about this i
there's a lot of people that already
know a lot more about me and that's
always opportunity for me to learn
things and to see if i can
contribute in some way so i just
acknowledge some
collaborators here either past or future
or present
a team spanning berkeley at mit i think
this team will grow
over time it probably has already grown
um so let me not go through the details
on this slide just
you can see i guess someone else
prepared this slide i guess there's the
prisoners dilemma up there in the upper
right
but let me make a few kind of uh
possibly slightly provocative comments
about game theory mechanism design
machine learning statistics and so on so
forth
uh first of all i don't think that these
kind of blends that we're talking about
are new in any real way
in fact i i'd like to point to david
blackwell as a person
who is equally comfortable in economics
and statistics and uh algorithms
um and you know wald and others even
even before blackwell
uh you know span these fields so i think
uh this is kind of trying to
re-energize it and innovate and the kind
of paths that they've already taken
for modern reasons and using some some
newer tools
so anyway let me uh characterize a
little bit game theory mechanism design
um classically the focus has been on
prior knowledge you assume
that either all the preferences are
known in some sort of a game
or perhaps that the distributions are
known and particularly if you don't know
the distributions it's sort of hard to
say
much of anything so a lot of the field
has
especially met this design revolved
around bayesian assumptions where i
assume i know the the priors
for everybody and then i uh derive some
consequences for that about for example
what bids i might make
um or or what matchings i might prefer
and and so on
um so you have to assume assume that
lots lots of things are known
um and this doesn't really accord very
well with the modern world where we
might have
uh hundreds of millions of entities uh
either agents or
or products or items or something and
there's no way that you're going to have
known preferences over all those things
you have to somehow experience them
and so there's got to be more of a focus
on learning and of course the word
learning appears in microeconomics but
it's it's a bit of a limited usage it's
really repeated experience with the game
um the notion of learning statistically
and making models of agents and
and model models of interactions
is is somehow less present and i think
that's where many of the opportunities
lie and of course i'm not alone in
asserting this uh
a lot of the work in the ec field has
has kind of moved in this direction from
just pure algorithm of game theory
to kind of data informed algorithm date
theory um
okay so i might add that i do have a lot
of respect for econometrics it's been
the
area where statistics has interfaced
with economics
um but largely it's been about just the
measurement problem
you know how do we feed you know
especially with macroeconomics how do we
feed
and how do we verify assumptions and
measure things i mean we want to do
something
much more ambitious uh really having you
know
learning and data analysis kind of
agents embedded in game theory
um now on the other side of the coin is
where where i'm a little more familiar
um let's think about machine learning
and think about how much embrace it has
had of microeconomics
and i'd say very little in particular
the latest wave of hype and
and activity on machine learning it's
all been a bit about pattern recognition
and sort of no focus really on decision
making
um and so you could be uh you know
excused by thinking that well decisions
are just that's a threshold of a neural
network isn't it
um and you know that's just not a very
helpful way to think
um in in in non-consequential problems
like is there a bunny in the image or
something maybe
um but if it's like um you know doctor
measure all kinds of things about my
body and my genome and so on telling me
whether i'm about to have a heart attack
you know or should i have an operation
that's a consequential decision and it's
not just a threshold you're going to
have a dialogue with the doctor
you're going to consider various
counterfactuals you're going to think
about the provenance of the data how
relevant is the data to what my current
decision is
and you're going to bring new
perspectives on your decision that will
come out in part of the dialogue kind of
much more like an economics uh
kind of thinking uh you know a decision
in economics involves thinking through
things
um moreover you're never going to just
have one decision you're almost always
going to have sets of decisions and
they'll probably be across a network
involving other people
you have to worry about the overall
errors over the entire set so things
like false discovery rate really need to
take over from
things like precision recall accuracy
where the pattern recognition people are
focused
then you have them over time and i don't
just mean you know
we introduce a time axis i mean over
long stretches of time maybe years
you know decisions were gonna you know
the data was collected 10 years ago but
it's still relevant maybe
if i can kind of think about that and so
there's asynchronous there's different
time scales
and then particularly for the purpose of
this talk there's decisions when there's
scarcity and competition
and so this uh has not been the focus of
much of machine learning people just
haven't worried about it
they've just you know done the optimal
quote-unquote decision or maybe the
optimal sequence in a reinforcement
paradigm
but they rarely thought about how does
that interact with uh you know other
decisions that might be made when their
scarcity
so there is a bit of work on multi-agent
rl um you know but i'm i think there's a
lot still to do there i don't think that
field is very mature at this point
um so my one of the sort of thought
experiments i've done to help me get
thinking about these issues is just to
consider classical recommendation
systems so these are pattern recognition
systems
they're not really decision making
systems per se um
so they look for patterns and data you
know you know what they are we have
customers making purchases
you kind of cluster purchases or
customers or both
and you make recommendations of new
things that a customer may wish to
purchase
um so it's become a commodity you can
download software to do it and people
just roll it out in various new kinds of
domains
now for domains like books and movies it
just it's not not unreasonable a lot of
us use it you know amazon and other
places it's been very effective
but as soon as you start to you use it
in wider range of domains
where there really is scarcity you run
into some
sort of obvious but non-trivial problems
um so consider
that you know amazon recommends you know
to maybe a million people a day you know
of books
or or movies or some other entities
uh you know it's very likely they'll
recommend the same book or movie to you
know 100 000 people
in a given day just because it's popular
or for or just plus on statistics
right and that's fine in that domain
there's no scarcity you can copy the
book or the movie all
as many times you want but if you
recommend say
you say build a recommendation system to
recommend restaurants to people
um if it's just some web app and no
one's really using it it's fine
um but if it's really real consequential
app
in other words everyone in the city is
really using it um
you know then people are going to punch
the button to try to get recommendations
and there's a good chance that you know
10 000 people will be recommended the
same restaurant
and now you're sort of stuck either you
say well that's a load balancing problem
i just got to kind of you know
randomly choose or something um or you
got to know a lot about the people
um you know kind of like oh i know their
browser history so i know so much about
them i can figure out which restaurant
they want to go to
and i think you can see that those are
both kind of ridiculous perspectives
unfortunately they're kind of common in
the i.t industry
um and a much more reasonable
perspective is to think about this like
an economics
person would and say oh well i need to
create a market i've got to
you know make make a market happen and
it's a very large scale market there
might be you know 100 000 restaurants in
you know in some
in shanghai and you don't know which one
you want to go to
um and it might be 100 million people
you know
thinking they would like to go to a
restaurant um same kind of things
happens when you recommend streets to
drivers if very few people are using it
it's fine but as soon as you
really roll it out in the real world a
lot of people are using it you'll create
congestion
and so then you've got to worry about
well who should go down which street
where should i
put people so i don't create congestion
and again if you do that top down
uh or randomly you're going to leave a
lot of economic value on the table
because some people are in a hurry and
other people are not in a hurry and you
really need to let that kind of utility
come into the decision making of this
machine learning system
all right um okay so um
you know it's kind of obvious what you
should be doing here you don't just
create a recommendation system
you create a two-way market to increase
producers consumers
now you might have recommendations on
both sides of that market
all right customers that have gone into
certain restaurants um
there's a hundred thousand restaurants
there's no way i will have a preference
over all of them
but maybe my friends have been to lots
of them and their recommendations can
inform my preferences and i don't have
to explore all those options
and i can build a healthier more
efficient market if i'm using
recommendation systems
and that could happen on the producer
side of the market as well
all right so the argument here is that
you just bring in some mechanism design
and game theory
but it's not just classical
microeconomics because we have um
large numbers of entities and we have
experiences and we have kind of bandit
problems emerging here where you're
trying out alternatives and seeing what
works
and that's what's informing the ongoing
game
all right so that's kind of you know
it's a trivial problem at some level but
it's a
i hope you see kind of an ambitious
blend to figure out how to design these
systems how to prove things about them
how to investigate robustness and and so
on and so forth
um i'm going to skip that slide um
all right so here's just a few problems
uh that you know costas and i kind of
talked a bit and
here's some of the ones we wrote down um
you know so multi-way markets in which
individual agents need to explore to
learn their preferences i've already
kind of alluded to that
large-scale multi-way markets in which
agents view other sides of the market
via recommendation systems not just
directly but
by recommendations you know issues
around information sharing free writing
signaling kind of things how do you
learn by what other people are telling
you and how do you put that in
in a uh you know competitive context or
cooperative context
you know auctions in which preferences
are learned incentive aware
classification and evaluation
and uh fairness privacy and social good
often these are talked about separately
from an economics perspective you know i
just i have a neural net it should be
fair it should you know
match some marginal probabilities or
something um
and you know my perspective is that
that's fine but it's just way too
limited that you need
some notion of economics here there
should be trade-offs and utilities
coming into play
when you talk about fairness and also
for privacy i i don't have an
infinite need for privacy and all
problems privacy varies depending on
other value i may get out of letting
data be revealed
so the goal then is more broadly even is
to discover new principles that are
allowed to that allow us to build
healthy for example fair learning based
markets that are stabilized over long
stretches of time
and this would be a longer talk but i
really want if it's this long stretch of
time
issue again to criticize machine
learning it's kind of like you gather a
huge data set and for that one day
it kind of works but the next day things
may have changed and you have to gather
a new data set you have to worry about
distribution shift and so on and so
forth
and just compare and contrast to markets
which can work for you know decades or
centuries
and they sort of adjust and heal
themselves on the fly a little bit more
now of course markets have all kinds of
problems and all kinds of issues and
and they're not just solved problem um
you know but they do have
other properties that are that are
valuable that machine learning just
doesn't seem to have as easily and
naturally and so the blend
seems to me extremely well motivated um
and of course you're going to need new
kinds of markets um you know just like
kind of new kinds of ecg mechanisms to
explore where people started to look at
you know
you know for example ad placement we're
going to need all kinds of new market
principles to
to blend really effectively with machine
learning and so there's just huge
opportunities here this is a slide from
costas actually and let me just
click there um which is to get a little
more into the
machine underlying all of this what kind
of algorithms are we going to be talking
about
as we start to explore this thing and
you know start to develop theory and so
on
and um um this is a useful thesis to
consider that
minimization has been surprisingly
important for a current machine learning
or ai
um and so min max optimization is is
what's needed to you know to go beyond
that it's one of the things that's
needed to go beyond that
or equilibrium learning if you will
having multiple agents that all
are following some gradient algorithm
perhaps of some kind and the overall
system uh works effectively um so this
is you know challenging we have these
you know conflicting aligned interests
and we got to work all that out
we may have adversaries we may have
constraints um
and just even basic gradient descent
itself
doesn't actually converge um so just
even the simplest possible algorithm
which
you know kind of works for minimization
doesn't work here and you already have
to do some
extra work right from the get-go um
this is also a slide that i that i
borrowed from costas
um just uh following up a bit on that
point
that um one of the oh really still open
problems is to identify gradient based
or or other similarly lightweight
methods
maybe not using hessians or maybe using
hessians or something else
that allow you to find equilibrium games
and these don't have just to be nash
equilibria they can be
you know sequential or stackelberg
equilibrium or other kinds
and they're in fact probably more
relevant to the problems we're
interested in
all right so that's just a big class of
problems that are as open as you know 10
years ago kind of accelerated gradient
was open
now you know a baby version of this
which is still quite open it's just
just look at two players zero sum games
and you've got now high dimensional x
and y and you maybe have non-convex and
non-concave f
um so just a few pieces of recent
progress on these topics
in fact uh costas and i have a paper
with yellow and a diacona collis
um uh finding families of non-convex
non-concave uh
functions where uh gradient descent
ascent actually does
is provably uh works and works
efficiently okay so
um kind of coming up from the bottom and
and
getting rid of some of the really bad
cases that uh kind of make the general
theory i'm not very
useful but um focus on some more
tractable
models um and
then acostas has a line of work with
other with colleagues
looking at where gda succeeds um
you know again kind of exploiting
various forms of structure
and then as well kind of lower bounds
for these kind of classes of problems
anyway so lots and lots to do they're
not not enough people are working on all
these things
um in my second half of the of the
presentation i'm gonna
um just mention one particular project
i've been doing with lydia liu and joria
mania grad students working
here at berkeley which again it's a very
simple problem very simple setup so i
think it's great for
introductory talk it just brings
together one learning problem with one
microeconomics problem and
sort of looks at what starts to happen
when you put the two together
um you know not entirely novel things
like this have been looked at but
you know the new tools are being used
here um
so multi-arm bandits are my favorite
version of learning problem
supervised learning is all well and good
but you're being kind of told the answer
in supervised learning that's not really
kind of learning in some sense
multi-armed bandits are no one's telling
you the answer you've got to learn
what's the right thing to do and so you
have to explore and then you want to
exploit while you're exploring and so
you all know the setup
you pull an arm you get a reward there's
some unknown reward distribution
you don't want to find the distribution
but you want to you know find enough
about the distribution so it guides you
and making good choices
all right and you perhaps know that um
there's
a number of algorithms that do this
pretty effectively uh ucb
uh algorithm um is
uh you know simple and it's a
frequentist algorithm it's
analyzed with frequencies tools
particularly use confidence intervals
and you put a confidence interval around
the reward the mean reward for each of
the arms okay so you're not getting the
whole distribution just a confidence
interval for the mean reward
and then you pick the upper confidence
bound to decide which action to pick
next
and so there's you either pick that
because it has already a high reward and
the
you know the confidence interval is
straddling the mean and it's high
or because it's high because you have a
very wide confidence
bound and you don't you have too much
uncertainty about that arms you should
pick it to reduce your uncertainty
so those two ideas are embodied in one
algorithm
and as you may know um if you analyze
the regret of this algorithm
you you get logarithmic regret um or
square root under certain
different kinds of assumptions but if
you know uh subliminally regret it
learns
um okay so that's on the learning side
on the
microeconomic side let's look at
matching markets you know gail shapley
roth et cetera et cetera um you know so
as all you know you have buyers on one
side supply
sellers on the other and you assume that
preferences are known here
so you know buyer number one prefers
seller one to
seller three and prefer seller three to
seller two
um and so on so we have on both sides of
the market we have preferences known
and then we'd like to find a matching
and as you probably all know
uh there's there's various algorithms
gail and shapley's algorithm um
runs from the buyer side makes offers or
makes pro
you know proposes matches and um
and that yields a match which is a
stable matching
okay it's efficient algorithm that does
this and it's a simple
easy to understand algorithm okay so the
a clear
research project that has a little bit
of the flavor of things i was talking
about earlier like you know large-scale
um recommendation systems
is to put matching markets together with
bandit learning okay so in other words
what if
you don't know those preferences so i've
got to start to explore
the other side of the market and figure
out which of the entities over there i
like
and then hopefully start to get matched
to those entities via
a you know gail shapley type algorithm
okay so now each one of the participants
has an exploration exploitation problem
they want to hone in on the arms that
looks the best for them
and they don't know up here which those
are so they have to they have to explore
but there's the other agents which are
exploring as well and that's gonna
obviously interact with each agent and
that may
uh help my exploration process or it may
hinder it
and we want to model those sorts of
things all right so here's a little
picture
uh two agents uh a human and a bear and
they're both picking arms
and the question kind of comes down to
what happens when both agents pick the
same arm
so in our model which is a little
different than what has been looked at
in the classical literature
classical literature was a kind of
congestion channel um
you know for packets on the internet um
or wireless
so if two agents would pick the same
channel then neither of them would get
the channel you know you'd put noise
into the channel
here we assumed more of an economic
model where uh
if two agents pick the same arm one of
them gets the reward
the other gets a zero of course they
know they get they did not get the
reward
um so who gets the reward well
the arms have also preferences back on
the agents
and those are unknown and perhaps
stochastic um
and uh so the learners are figuring out
that i like arm two
but i see when i pick arm two it seems
like arm two prefers the bear
and so the human will say well i better
start exploring the other arms more than
i otherwise
would so in this model it seems likely
you're going to pay an exploration
penalty
a necessary one by the presence of the
other agents in the problem
all right so our model then is we have
abandoned market agents on one side arms
on the other
and um when multiple arms pull the s
eight suppose the same arm only one of
them gets the reward uh so now
to start to do some some theory here you
need to define
a natural criterion uh some form of
regret
um so what we've done in our first line
of work is
is to take the mean reward of a stable
match so kind of imagine you ran gail
shapley on
known preferences if that were the case
then you'd get a match and let's suppose
you did that on all of the end trials
that would give you that first term in
the regret there so we compare our
actual reward received to that
so mean reward of a staple match
um and we've analyzed an algorithm um
we've analyzed several algorithms but
let me just mention this first one
uh let's call this gail chaplin upper
confidence bound so this one is actually
a centralized algorithm
so here agents just rank arms like they
usually do they form an upper confidence
bound for each arm
and they start to learn which arm they'd
like to pick but they don't get
just pick the arm they submit these
rankings they submit the upper
confidence bound to a matching platform
so they don't submit a mean reward
they submit an upper confidence bound
and then gail shapley runs on the on the
ucb values
it returns a matching and then you're
allowed to experience the reward from
the arm that you've been matched to
okay so that's our algorithm and we are
able to analyze that
and find out that in fact you do achieve
a logarithmic regret here
um so that's up in the numerator and the
denominator there's a term
delta which we have an expression for
which is a
a reform of reward gap and it depends on
the presence of the other agents
so again if the bear is picking the same
arm that i see my
like i want to pick that that gives me a
gap
a difference but not just between the
arms but also between the agents
and i'm going to pay a penalty uh i'll
have larger regret because of that
happening
also the last bullet on the slide is
important it turns out that this
algorithm is incentive compatible
so meaning that if everyone else is
playing gs ucb
i am not i am incentivized to play ugs
ucb as well i'm not incentivized to move
away and play
some other algorithm um
okay uh last few minutes and i think
i'll close a little bit early
if i remember i have 30 minutes um so um
so we've been working for the last that
paper is about a year old we've been
working for last year on decentralized
models
and i have three separate projects in my
group all decentralized working on this
problem
and we have three papers coming out
which all are all different
um i'm going to mention the one that
follows on with work with lydia and
herrea
and we've added um a fun rule on to the
group as well
um but the other ones are a little
different and also interesting and so
you'll
you'll find them on my publications page
um
so um anyway it's a more challenging
problem and
i i don't think there's you know
necessarily an obvious best solution
here yet at least so
anyway the decentralized setting is that
players don't communicate with each
other or with a platform
okay so kind of the more realistic model
i had in mind which is that you're
walking around looking for a restaurant
um you know you may just kind of want to
have a local connection between you and
the restaurants
um so the the model here is that each
player is going to pull
attempt to pull an arm and when multiple
arms pull the same
arm the most preferred arm by the uh
player
by the arm wins and is matched so that's
like the model i was talking about
and you get a reward for your match
otherwise you don't and you can see the
successful matches but you don't get to
see the other player's rewards
of course that's an interesting model of
itself if you get to see the other
player's rewards
there can be kind of an information
sharing or free writing kind of thing
that could be studied as well
certainly of interest all right so this
problem is more challenging there can be
conflict cycles that arise
among the decentralized players and this
can be costly so it has to be taken to
account
and uh regret bounds for general
preference structures
the ideas that we were using before
based on gail shapley just don't apply
and so we've had to come up with some
new ideas here and so let me just
mention
the uh uh the paper that's about
ready to come out we'll finish it within
a week or two uh that looks at a random
delays version of ucb so it
avoids conflicts with random delays so
we're trying to keep this as simple as
possible so we can both analyze it plus
we
might hope that people would actually
use it so here uh
players are going to construct a kind of
set of plausible arms a
a seed set of arms by looking at
successful matches from the previous
time step
okay um and then independently with the
probability
p you're going to attempt the same arm
as at time t minus one
okay so we're gonna have geometric
probabilities we have a geometrization
of the problem going on
and with probability one minus p we're
going to um
attempt the arm in the plausible set
with the highest ucb so we bring in the
ucb
exploration exploitation uh
probabilistically
and then you received arms from matched
arms and update their ucb okay so it's a
pretty simple
little mechanism where there's just a
bit of geometric randomness being added
all right and we are able to get a um
a theorem here a regret bound
uh if they're in players and n arms um
and for a value p between zero and one
the there's a notion of pessimal stable
regret here
so you know there's optimal and pessimal
um so of the
attainable arms i'm guaranteed to get
the worst among my attainable arms
um that's what the notion of pessimal is
here
and of course it's the stable regret
it's relative to dale shapley
so the the pessimist stable regret of
arm
a player i satisfies uh this bound here
so it's uh it's poly logarithmic and
it's got an interesting
and funny exponential factor in there
which would be lovely to try to remove
um but it's in there kind of for a
reason and then we have again our
nice interpretable gap in the
denominator
um so we can get rid of that quadratic
on the logarithm
under certain assumptions so for example
if all arms have the same preferences
over all players
it turns out that you get just just a
pure logarithm okay so these are all
upper bounds
no lower bounds as of yet and you know
not entire clarity about what's going to
kind of be the best rate and what you
can get here
um but anyway that's where we're at with
the problem um
all right so let me finish up um i'm
gonna have two finishing up slides one
for me and one from costas
so um this is mine which just kind of go
back up to the very top
level you know machine learning a lot of
progress but really
uh kind of overly focused in my view on
pattern recognition over the last few
years
uh grading descent and label data and
patterns and even unlabeled data but
just still finding patterns
and uh it's become a commodity it's
widely used but it's widely misused too
because people aren't thinking about the
consequences of the decisions based on
these kind of systems
and you know instead of just saying hey
we're not thinking enough about it we
should work more on it
we already been working on this and we
have a lot to say about decision making
but we got to kind of step forward and
say well we're gonna we know how to talk
about decision making
you know false discovery rates
microeconomic principles you know regret
and so on and so forth but we got to
talk about it in these high-stakes
situations and talk about really doing
in the real world at real scale
and particularly bringing in market
mechanisms
um okay actually that's the last slide i
had so i am done and uh if there's time
for questions or i don't know how you're
running it
yeah yeah yeah so we have we have a
couple of minutes for questions
um while people are working out how to
use the q a feature
let me ask um your your learning
matching markets here has this asymmetry
between
between agents and arms right the agents
don't know the preference over the years
the arms know the restaurants know in
advance who's going to pay up
um you know what do you know if both
have uncertainty
yeah we don't know i mean the there
there's a natural symmetry in the
problem formulation and the actual
analysis we've done it's not so
symmetric
really it's focused on the bandit side
you know the agents are learning
and the arms are not learning in the
current setup so they have
unknown preferences but they're not
being learned and so i think uh you know
obvious
next steps are to have the agents sorry
the um
the right-hand side of the market also
doing the learning and actually restore
a little bit of the symmetry it's much
harder
um but you know another one of the kind
of super interesting problems on the
list of things to work on
all right fantastic thanks mike i have a
question for mike as well
so mike would it make some sense to give
the arms some way to
they might have preferences but you
might prefer
uh pewter over me but i'm willing to pay
more for the restaurant so you said them
i have to serve christian
yeah yeah no great question um so first
of all
um in an example like that you can sort
of see there's a real asymmetry that we
kind of
like it when the arms sorry when the the
players
share information you know but this is a
good restaurant you should all go there
we don't so much like it when the
restaurants share information
it starts we get into privacy issues and
how come you pick those guys versus
these there's legal issues
so you know it's it's interestingly
different there that's first point the
second point is that you're bringing in
prices
and auctions and bids and all that and i
totally
want to do that and agree you need to do
that um but it
really complicates the situation um you
know it
conceptually could it could make the
situation simpler but it it's uh it's a
matching market with prices
and uh very much more uh complicated
piece of mathematics
um and so we didn't kind of go there as
our first step but i i totally agree
i mean i really do like to have this
concrete model in mind though i walk
into
you know i'm in shanghai i'm walking
around i got my cell phone out
i push a button say i want dinner and
just like the uber kind of market i want
then the restaurants around to kind of
respond to that in some sense
right and i want to then be able to
easily you know
in some sense make a bid or have them
make a bid for me
so i kind of like the restaurants to say
hey we're looking at you you're really
relevant you like our kind of food
you know that's the recommendation part
and um we're going to make a bid you
know if you come for the next 10 minutes
we'll make you a five percent discount
and um and i look at my best offer and i
accept one and uh
so yeah i'd like to have a notion of
auctions and bids and all that in a
situation like that but um
i see so you're thinking of some
restaurants we should stop it there
christian we're we're out of time yeah
thanks very much mike appreciate it all
right you bet
thank you fantastic so um our next
speaker is uh philippe
rigole um philippe's a professor in
mathematics at mit
he